We're continuing to get to know this new class
of elected officials in the House of Representatives,
which includes some really, really unqualified
people, we've spoken before about Marjorie
Taylor Green, who drafted articles of impeachment
against Joe Biden on January 21st last week.
Yes, she did.
We talked earlier today about Lauren Bobert.
We spoke earlier today about Madison Catherines
disastrous interview on CNN.
You know, to give you a sense of the sort
of folks that we're dealing with here, there
is pretty widespread reporting about Madison
Cawthorn visiting Hitler's house because it
was a bucket list item for him and everything
about I mean, down to the detail, this is
indistinguishable from satire with some of
these guys.
The Jewish mayor of Ashville, North Carolina,
remember that Madison Cawthorn is a representative
now in North Carolina back in August, said
it's very concerning that the Republican then
candidate, now a member of Congress, visited
Adolf Hitler's vacation home and referred
to him as the Führer on social media.
And back in 2017, Cawthorn posted from the
called the Eagle's Nest, Hitler's vacation
home.
It was one of the last battlegrounds of World
War Two, referred to Hitler as the Führer
said that going there was on his bucket list
and did call Hitler a supreme evil.
Right.
I'm not looking to hide that from you, the
mayor Mannheimer said.
It's very concerning.
Throughout the last several years, since Trump
has been elected president, I think all of
us have seen that white supremacists are emboldened
and are publicly making their positions known.
And to elect someone who openly throws out
dog whistles like this, it just makes me really
sad, actually.
First and foremost, it makes me sad, disappointed,
worried.
Now, when this was written about, Cawthorn
briefly took down the pictures because a lot
of attention was called to them.
Then they were publicly visible.
Again, Cawthorn deciding to double down and
to say that it's a fake news controversy,
that he wasn't there to celebrate.
He was celebrating a victory over evil.
So I have a few different thoughts about this.
First of all, as someone who who is disabled,
Madison Cawthorn would have been one of the
first killed by the Nazis right after Jews.
So that the irony of that is certainly not
lost on me.
You'll very often hear defenses from these
folks like, no, I was interested in seeing
how such evil was defeated.
Or sometimes you'll hear a little more about,
well, it was interesting for historical reasons,
visiting Hitler's vacation home.
I'm a I'm an historian and it was interesting
for that or reading.
Mein Kampf is interesting for historical reasons.
I enjoy history as well.
But when you see people flocking to the Hitler
stuff for history's sake, but they're not
interested in any other areas of history,
it is a little weird, right?
Like if Mein Kampf is the only history book
you read, you might not be that interested
in history.
And Mein Kampf isn't even really a history
book.
It's a historical book for sure.
But it's not a book about history.
I'm no expert, but very often when people
gravitate to Hitler's vacation home or reading
Mein Kampf and like, that's the only curiosity
they have.
It's not really about history.
It's that they find the legacy of power and
violence and ruthlessness exciting or interesting.
And it's I'm not denying that Madison Cothran
thinks Hitler was evil in some kind of nominal
way.
What I am sure of is that Cawthorn is a reactionary
and a liar, and we should be very careful
about believing anything he says.
And I don't know how many of you are aware
of the history of lying.
Madison Cawthorn misled the public about claiming
he was training for the Paralympics.
He misrepresented his educational history.
He misrepresented his business history.
This seems like just a liar.
Which reminds me of someone, by the way, multiple
outlets have reported that before running
for office, Cawthorn said he was training
for the 2020 Paralympic Games.
There's no evidence of that whatsoever.
Cawthorn wasn't on any team or club.
He didn't run any races.
It sort of be like if I said I'm training
for Olympic ski jumping.
What have you done?
Any skiing to prepare?
No.
Do you have a coach know?
Are you on any team?
No.
Do you have a lift ticket anywhere?
But I'm training like that's the degree to
which it seems that he was training.
Cawthorn claims to have been a successful
business owner and heading to the Naval Academy
when his tragic car accident left him paralyzed.
But the truth is he had already been rejected
from the Naval Academy, so it wasn't true
he was heading there.
His only business that anyone was able to
find was a real estate investment company
that had zero income and no employees in twenty
nineteen.
So this seems like a liar.
And when you talk about someone that gets
elected merely riding, riding the wings or
standing on the coattails of Donald Trump
and the Trump cult, this is exactly who would
you would imagine gets elected and will be
doing deep dives into.
Lauren Bowerbird will be doing deep dives
into Marjorie Taylor Green.
These are folks who know nothing about policy
or governance.
They are the epitome of cultish role players.
And we saw that in Madison Catherines Pamela
Brown interview earlier on in the show.
And so these folks really have to be defeated
in twenty twenty two.
If Republicans learned anything from Trump
in the Trump fiasco, and I don't know that
they have, but as I said earlier, if they
learned anything from the Trump fiasco, they
would make sure to run credible primaries
against these folks or to convince them to
retire and that they can't win.
I don't know that that's actually going to
happen.
But these folks, if they get reelected, would
cement this Trump and cult in the House of
Representatives from multiple terms.
And that would be really, really scary and
an absolutely horrible thing.